gelobt wird schon heute herzlich
willkommen zu einer essen testen spezial
morgen absolut spezial und zwar weil es
bisher immer nach dem prinzip gemacht
ich habe überall und der bringt thomas
mester fest wird das was ihm nicht
gefällt
heute steht im mittelpunkt der sich bei
der große abstimmung machen lassen in
der die rheinstraße konnte ist welche
lebensmittel ihr persönliches und max
nicht testen die heute ich würde sagen
max wie siehst du nicht
[Musik]
ich bin zwar max konnte nichts dafür
müssten wir kommen
hallo michael schön dass sie da sind ich
will sagen
überhaupt nimmt wahr was raus mit diesem
entspannte gehen stehen gerade ganz
entscheidend weil jeder weg aus den
anfangs war für die katz gewesen
ich habe zufällig gerade schon das
wasser abgezogen ich nur sagen auch ich
nehme zuschauer
ihr habt euch entschieden habt kind kann
gemacht aber mittlerweile finde ich sie
ganz lecker diese nicht sonderlich gut
aber trotzdem schmeckt gut sooo gaddafi
leute die jetzt vielleicht was ist das
für ein eigenes alter mobil ist ganz
normal ist jeder vor ort tatsächlich
dass wir leben holen sollen oliven
werden scheinbar so vielen leuten gehabt
habe also glaubt mir ich habe perverse
scheiße mitgebracht das ist nicht nur
sache und die eklig sind dies das ist
perverse scheiße und das testen wir aber
erstmal nur lieb mich diesen hinzu die
immer vor jetzt richtigen trinkt auch
was von mir sagen können so lieben sagt
die erste sache war einige t aber du
bist mag okay und ich bin jetzt auf
jeden fall wieder am start
schauen wir uns auch schon die zweite
sache an und so schlich ich hasse sind
jetzt halt auch nichts was ein purist
aber selbst von apparat muss auch gesagt
okay jetzt ist es mein chernin selbst zu
testen ich musste mir so komische
kalkulation weil ich kann diese giftige
masse nicht nur essen
du wirst kind gebraucht nahe junge ich
hab das ist nicht immer lustig sieht es
aber nicht aus der gosse und einfach nur
pech
[Musik]
und das ok habe ich erstens natürlich
kann das jetzt nicht zulassen würde
jeden tag aber man kann es genießen ganz
im gegensatz zu den sachen die wir noch
da haben leute ja es wird ihren los dann
meist siehst du die nächste sache daraus
muschel salat in aufguss ja die sache
ist einfach nur schön ich mag muscheln
nicht sozial cosmo schwenn
gehen wir mal ganz schön sind das ist
meines und das wieder nicht also ich
finde das richtig ist nicht okay ist
schon schlimm richtig schwitzen lecker
lecker dass es wieder das ist
ekelerregend leute ganz kurze zeit waren
gießen jogger auf diesem kanal
euro wahnsinn oder
boah das ist echt das ist echt die härte
seid froh dass kameras live übertragen
könnte sich künftig auch ja das zieht
aus sieht aus wie keine ahnung im
zaubertrank er von professor snape alter
der wird sich die sonne wieder rein war
dann die sachen sind einfach tot ist tot
die buschleute sebastian wir werden da
in ihren losen brachen riecht verdächtig
ich bin also sozusagen drin wäre ich
will hier raus rennen und nicht vom
balkon stürzen
note 1 14 auf mutter eines damals gar
drei hammer dass man miesmuscheln die
eine geile musste sind dass man nichts
mit der superzahl reiter was das war
okay mag es hier keinen blick in die
tüte geworfen wir haben drei dinge noch
drin
eine sache ist nicht lecker eine sache
ist fucking lecker aber die leute hätte
von einer sache ist die bewährteste
krank ist scheiße die die menschen sich
immer so aufgehört hat
die sache wie ich gemerkt daher mögen
das relativ ist okay was haben wir hier
lakritz salzige herings das ist aber das
schlimmste ist witzig finde es gibt so
richtig kraft sagt so stark schmeckt so
richtig sei
die haben dazu ihre süße dass man hier
doch da also wenn ich etwas flüssigkeit
mit manager kritt hunn aber ich mache
das kurz zu meiner beziehung zu leicht
war es riecht schon wie tod und
verderben
wir kommen der jetzt mit süßigkeit
sondern seitlich festigkeit und ich kann
es mir spaß macht wird sie aber ich
nehme meine sachen raus hat sich das
rücken gemacht ja ich nehme
drückt man bei den schülern worauf er zu
sparen die andere war nämlich in diesem
leben als er einfach marzipan gewesen so
viele leute gesagt marzipan finden
ekelhaft
das macht das verbrechen gegen die
menschheit
ich kann's nicht erst ja ich auch mich
das ist einfach so war hat es so halte
wenn ich das nicht gegangen werden wenn
ich das wirklich gebrochen sein
mit gurken stimmten sich die bands ist
es in buchen
wir richten da kommen berichtet ok du
fliegst im ersten test okay wer ist für
diese missgeburt verantwortlich
[Musik]
es gibt halt auch mal glück bestimmt
keine ahnung nur fersen
die gegner erwarten wir die hersteller
die kriegen so was auch den exklusiven
treffen so in der u 23 aus trifft man
sich dann kriegt man seine speziellen
öffner das soll ich die konzerne auf den
kann eigentlich menschenfleisch ist
wieder den kopf ich führe bei waters
geht nicht auf 5 finkel probieren die
leute zu schützen
ok ich auch von den medien abgeben
okay leute dann jetzt zum abschied noch
ganz kurz und so greifbar ist das geil
junge ohne willst das ist wie kuchenteig
gut ab und marzipan während euch recht
diese tödliche substanz
das ist aber bereit mehr das macht sich
bald euch nicht einmal auf die paar
kugeln an weihnachten genau gemeint ist
wohl der erste mord des lng ist dann
schluss für die dauer von einer sekunde
tps kleine rote dass von diesen videos
die süße wir hätten sie gern gegessen
aber wir haben nicht die eier dazu die
sitze bleibt der endgegner weil die
vielleicht hätten wir diese ok dazu
normalerweise kann ich solche mega ab
nicht aber mark hat keine folgen
deswegen bei 20.000 likes auf diesem
video essen wir die sitze vor kamera mit
beweis und sterben max ist völlig leute
und hier drüben findet ihr noch eine
aktuelle folge von wassers geht falls
die jetzige sachen gesehen habt und
jetzt bisschen entlastung braucht jetzt
hier weiter dank für zu schaffen
[Musik]